بمجرد إطلاق قذيفة مدفعية
باتجاه بحمود،
يهرع الطاقم للاستعداد لهجوم آخر.
أبلغ المسؤولون الأوكرانيون عن مكاسب حول
المدينة التي أصبحت منذ العام الماضي
مركزًا
للمدفع الحربي، وكان القائد أرتيم في المنطقة
منذ أشهر
بمهمة إزالة الإحداثيات  في
أوامر النباح أصبحت روتينية الآن، يقول إنه
الآن نصف أصم من الانفجار
ومع ذلك فقد شعر بالتغيير، يبدو
الأمر وكأنهم غالبًا ما يهربون، كما
يقول في إشارة إلى الروس
ثم أمر إطلاق النار،
حسنًا،
بالكاد هناك توقف في المسافة البعيدة
ثلث القصف
الروسي يقول إن إشارة نداء المدفعي أن
برج الحمل يتراجع، ونحن نعلم أنهم
ضربونا أقل بكثير قبل شهر أو شهرين، كان
هناك الكثير من القصف الوارد، كان الأمر
مخيفًا أن أكون هنا الآن، الأمر مختلف
على جانب آخر، فالمدافع الكبيرة تخرج
هنا  هو بوجدانا أوكراني الصنع عيار 155
ملم،
تدعي أوكرانيا أن الروس أرسلوا
ما يصل إلى 50 ألف جندي
للدفاع عن المدينة المحفورة بعمق،
وقد حصن الروس
مواقعهم وصمدوا بقوة،
أخبرني القائد ديميترو ولكن أعتقد أن هذا هو
الجنود الروس المؤقتون الذين تم أسرهم  في المعركة
هنا أخبرنا أن القصف على
مواقعهم كان بلا هوادة،
حيث تم إطلاق ذخيرة شديدة الانفجار مضادة للأفراد
في اتجاه
القوات الروسية خارج باكموت
بمجرد إطلاق النار
استعدوا لإطلاق النار مرة أخرى